Mission Impossible.
This box will self-destruct in five seconds.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
Greatest back of the box in the history of the show?
Did it self-destruct?
I'm pretty sure one kid in America's copy self-destructed after they read it.
That'd be pretty spooky.
You have to read it, though.
I think that's like a really bad creepypasta.
If you don't read the text, you wouldn't know it was happening, so there's no payoff for it.
So it was like something about like they were using eye tracking software to make sure you read the whole box and then it would self-destruct five seconds after you read the entirety of the box.
And then it's like, I'm right behind you.
And the box uses all that same kind of spy language and everything, and they really commit to it.
Because even in the manual, there's all sorts of like, not just spy terminology, but just like this whole theme about like a mission briefing throughout the whole thing of like how to use your controller and how the screens work.
Like it's all like it's debriefing you.
And I feel like we've seen that before, but I do appreciate the attention to detail here on Mission Impossible, which is obviously, you know, not the movies.
This is not the Tom Cruise Mission Impossible thing that hasn't happened yet.
First Mission Impossible movie was like what?
96? 96, yeah.
Yeah. So we're in 1990, but there is a TV show that was out from 88 to 90 that was basically like a revival of the series from the 60s.
So if you're paying attention, we're going backwards.
We'll go forward now.
There was a TV series in the 60s.
There's a shorter lived TV series in the late 80s.
And then now, of course, Mission Impossible is a huge big brand name for Paramount as a movie franchise with Tom Cruise.
Guys, let's start first with the movies since they're the biggest.
What's your familiarity with them?
I'm pretty familiar with all of them.
I recently marathoned them because, you know, when I was when I was younger, I didn't really know much about them.
But then later, I think it was after maybe Mission Impossible three.
I was I just I got I got into it.
And then after that, I kind of forgot.
And then later they just became like action movies without any filler at all.
And like that's sort of the case throughout.
And now I just have a deep appreciation for them.
And I'm looking forward to the final chapter at some point this year, I think.
So as probably a surprise to no one, I'm not super familiar with the franchise.
It is a surprise to me, though, because it seems like this is one where it's just like, how could I have avoided this?
And it also seems like my type of thing.
I've seen one of the films and it was like one of them.
It was like Mission Impossible six or something.
And I saw it in theaters and was like, wow, that was really good.
And then I remember hearing a lot about like a Mission Impossible.
The film series does not do what a lot of these other film franchises do and just kind of like get really, really bad over time that like they actually kind of hold a level of quality.
And I really do want to binge them and see if that holds true, because I did really like one of these later entries in the movie series.
So I've been planning on, you know, it's on my never ending, expanding list of things that I plan on watching that I probably never will.
Joe, it's funny you bring up about the franchise, not just getting like maybe you were thinking like Fast and the Furious style where it just gets more ridiculous over time.
Yeah, that's actually what caught my eye about it was like the directors that are attached to the movies.
Like I always associated it as a kid with Tom Cruise, but you've got De Palma, John Woo, J.J.
Abrams, Brad Bird.
Like that's pretty impressive lineup of directors continuously attaching themselves to this franchise.
Specifically, De Palma was the one that like after I was like the guy who made Blowout and Scarface made a Mission Impossible and it was the first one that I just didn't know.
So I went back and watched it.
And yeah, it's great.
It's great stuff. It's the American, the American James Bond kind of.
I like that.
Yeah, I think that's a that that is a good analogy.
It doesn't get as campy as Bond like Bond got really weird in the 80s with that stuff in late 70s.
But it isn't it isn't completely serious.
No, no, it's also very funny series.
Right. With the Simon Pegg.
Yes. What was I going to say next?
Oh, but the TV series, though, I had no memory or I feel like I've never seen it on TV.
Like I never found reruns of it or anything.
So I wasn't sure if like, well, is that like a serious spy thing or was this like a comedy thing?
Is this like, you know, for me, finding out about Mission Impossible as a TV show.
And I'm sorry to make people feel old in this way, but like finding out about Mission Impossible being a TV show was like when I found out 21 Jump Street was also like a TV show before it was the movie.
So I just don't have any attachment to the show.
You guys know anything about it?
So did you find this out like while researching for this episode or did you know this before that there was a TV series?
Like I found out about the Mission Impossible TV series while I was like, oh, that's what this is based on.
Not the movie. I knew that there was one in like the 60s or 70s.
I didn't know that there was one more recently.
Same, same. But I think this is like this is like one of those shows that like I feel like I've heard my dad talk about not to not to age my dad here.
But yeah, he's old enough to have watched Mission Impossible in the 60s.
So, yes, but but yeah, I think he used to talk about some of these and I imagine it was one of the shows again having never seen it, but just from what he's described, I imagine it was taking itself seriously, but maybe difficult to take seriously if we watched it now.
But like like the man from uncle or something like that, like one of those types of like it's like silly, but it thinks it's being serious.
Can you confirm Mike?
Like, yeah.
Yeah. No, I think that I think Joe's analogy of at the time, it would have been gripping.
And now it's like, you know, compared to the more serious spy thrillers or even just like, you know, crime dramas that we have, like it's just like NCIS.
Yeah, just yes, absolutely.
It just doesn't hold up to NCIS.
And so, you know, I think this is like one of those, you know, it came in as an as an NES game as the series was ending though, too.
So maybe there was like still hopes that like, you know, like the series was just going to continue getting renewed and this would just continue to bring more interest to it.
But but I don't know anything about the general plot structure of the show.
But I imagine every episode doesn't start with them logging into their computer at work and it's saying good morning, your boss and his secretary have been kidnapped.
No, no, no.
Which is how the game starts.
I do wonder now, like if every episode did have the self-destruct thing, if it was like a like a monster of the week kind of thing or if or if it was more serialized, that that's a good thought.
I don't know.
Well, in speaking of this like intro, it also kind of gives that iconic line, which I know from just the movies of your mission, if you choose to accept it is what I always heard.
And that's from the movies.
I'm assuming it's similar in the in the TV show.
But in here it says your mission, if you decide to accept it, which just I know it's just one minor word difference.
But that just feels so wrong to me.
Is that what it was?
It could make all the difference.
You're asking the wrong people, Joe.
I know. Speaking of speaking of iconic stuff, it also starts with the Mission Impossible theme, which is, you know, obviously famous for the movies now, too, but did exist on the TV show.
And Sean, you sung this out last week with that song with the main theme of Mission Impossible.
And my favorite rendition of the theme is Sean's version from what episode was that?
It's Mission Impossible in parentheses.
Sean's version. Sean.
Last week's episode was Maniac Mansion.
Yeah. The Maniac Mansion.
Sean's version rendition of the Mission Impossible theme is my favorite song of the year.
It's good stuff.
It's a good song.
Sean. In the game, you will control a team of three members of the Impossible Missions force, IMF, tasked with rescuing the-
Dr. O. And his secretary, who apparently in the manual maybe, somewhere I read this, is a fellow operative, so it was kind of rude to refer to her as a secretary.
Shannon Reed, from the terrorist group Sinister Seven.
Now, come on.
What kind of terrorist group just like- that's where it gets like back to the James Bond territory, right?
Of like, Spectre is a little more like ominous than Sinister Seven, right?
Like, this sounds like he's fighting Spider-Man and Electro and Venom and stuff like that.
It's just like, it's weird that they went through all the mission debriefing thing and then you take on like, you know, mini-me.
I do think this harkens back to a time, which I think it was more like a Cold War thing, where, you know, the enemies of the United States government were more outwardly, like, villainous on purpose.
Like, I think this was just a thing, like, and we're- it's just odd to our postmodern ears.
You mean they were actually outwardly villainous or were portrayed as more outwardly villainous?
I'm- I'm- I'm just making shit up, Joe.
Okay, I never know.
And you play as these- these three members of the IMF via a top-down perspective.
Uh, so you have Max, Grant, and Nicholas, and, uh, they can be switched freely, but not in like a Grand Theft Auto V kind of way, where, like, you switch between the three characters and it jumps over to wherever Max was left off or wherever, uh, Grant was left off.
It just switches to them as if they were all three of them were hanging out together going through this mission, and now they just automatically change into-
Right, like, tagged in.
Yeah. Uh, so, say what you will about the actual game and everything.
We'll get into that in a moment, but the first thing I gotta ask you guys is, why are they walking like that?
I don't know what you mean by like that.
Look- I think if you're gonna make it top-down to- to this extent, this is kind of like what it's gonna look like.
Yeah, I think that for me more-
They're doing the Mr.
McMahon shoulder swing.
My question was more like, man, why did they go so committed to the top-down?
Like, you could go top-down and be not quite this top-down.
I love it. Because it is literally directly overhead.
I'm a little biased because I think what I really like about this visual style is it looks so much like Hotline Miami.
And I think part of that- it also kind of plays like it, like a much more slow Hotline Miami in a way.
But I guess maybe my brain was just used to it from the countless hours of that game that I played.
So this- that didn't bother me that much.
My brain did get used to it over time.
But at first I thought I was playing as like all three Geodudes.
Just like their arms and their heads just like bobbing around.
Yeah, it's- it's strictly a graphical thing.
They do not walk in a way that hinders the gameplay at all.
They are not slow moving.
It's a slow-paced game in a way, but they're not walking slow or dragging along or anything.
It's just because of how bird's eye we are on this whole thing.
They just swing their shoulders very aggressively at times as they're walking around.
And you don't really see like their feet or their knees bending or anything.
So it's a little- it's a little strange just to see like that much shoulder swing.
So Joe, I like the Geodude analogy.
Now, Max, Grant, and Nicholas wouldn't be interesting if it was just switching between like health-
available health that they have, right?
Their life meters if you were just like, well, Max is about to die, so I'm just gonna switch into Grant.
They, of course, also similar to like how, you know, how we were talking about Castlevania 3.
Like they all have their own specialization stuff.
So Max is the combat specialist.
Grant is the technical guy.
And Nicholas is the master of disguise.
And you kind of have to think about the situation you're in and who you want to swap into.
But it's not like if one dies, they all die.
If you lose Nicholas, don't worry, you still have Max and Grant.
You can be down to just Max.
And so therefore, there has to be a way to get around this.
It's not like Grant's the only one who can, you know, disarm a bomb or open a gate or something like that.
Are there not instances specifically with Grant where you need him?
That's the only one that I couldn't figure out.
Like if I didn't have Grant, how would I get pet?
Because he opens these doors that like I feel like you couldn't open with other characters.
Sorry, which one is Grant?
Grant is the second guy he's got.
He punches. The middle guy.
And he can open the coded board doors.
I thought they all could open the coded doors.
I thought I just had to be Grant.
I just kept switching to Grant for those.
You can open the... Well, which ones are you talking about?
The ones in the first level or like in general?
Because the ones in the first level, don't they, aren't they like by sound?
Yeah, but I thought you had to be Grant in order to hear those sounds.
Like when I walk up to it as the other guy, it's just a wall.
I had to look it up to figure out how to get through.
Unless I was misunderstanding.
I didn't try it without Grant, so I can't say for certain.
I just didn't run.
I didn't hear about any soft locking like that.
Yeah, unless I misunderstood it and I was just Grant the whole time after looking it up.
I thought that the first time I went and walked into one of those doors as someone else, I was like, oh, it's just a wall.
And then I looked up where do I go and I said, oh, that wall, you use Grant to disarm that wall or something.
Interesting. Well, I mean, the other differences between them, I did appreciate that there were actual substantive differences between...
Like Mike mentioned, kind of like the vibes of each, but they all have different weapons, the different sub-weapons.
Or I guess in the guy in the rights case, tell me his name.
I think it's Nicholas.
Nicholas even has like that...
The one thing that kind of makes it feel like Mission Impossible that isn't the song or the name or the self-destructing, which is like the...
What do you call it?
What do they call that in the movies?
Like camouflage? No, it's like a face maker, which is like making him look like one of the guys and then the AI actually treats him as if there's no enemy there, which I think is really cool.
And then they also have different move speeds, which is very important, at least underground in the first level where you keep having to dodge falling sewage.
And so a quick thing, I did not realize how to change between characters, because this is one of those games I did not read the manual for, until pretty late.
And I was like, every time I walk by this falling sewage, I get hit.
So I'm going to die eventually.
And then I was like, oh, wait, no, this middle guy walks faster.
So, yeah, they all have their purposes.
Yeah, and I had a similar thing.
I knew how to change the characters.
I just didn't recognize how much quicker Grant walked than the other two.
I just thought, like, I recognized all the other differences.
I didn't realize that they had different walk speeds.
So that, I was a little pissed off at first.
I was like, what, you just can't get past this waterfall without taking a hit?
And then when I realized, but yeah, I mean, in traversal and in combat, like they each have different weapons where,
and now I'm confusing who has it.
So Nick has the camouflage.
Grant has, like, a stun grenade.
Is that Grant? Yeah, it's like sleepy gas.
Yeah, and that's helpful a lot of times, too, because there are a lot of enemies that are just, like,
constantly firing in one spot that you have to get past.
So, like, you know, that gives you some reason to use Grant.
And then the first guy who...
And luring them out isn't easy, Joe. Like, while we're on that, it's just like, you have to...
They'll stay stubbornly stuck in that spot where they're shooting.
Yes. It's not like they have, like, you know, a dedicated ammo that they'll eventually run out of.
You just have to kind of get into their view to have them chase at you.
Otherwise, they will just hide behind that corner continuously shooting at the player.
Right. And then speaking of getting them to chase after you, the other guy, the first guy...
Max. What's his name?
I could do this all day. Max.
Max has his, like, detonator bombs where you can, like, get one to chase you, put down
a bomb, and then detonate it at the right moment.
Like, and they're all kind of doing similar things, but it's fun.
Yeah, that's how I took care of Riot Shield, guys.
It's fun. Joe, while you were talking, I took the opportunity to just look up about the Grant thing of it all,
because I do think that's an important detail.
And yes, there are other ways to solve any of these puzzles without Grant,
but Grant is, I don't want to say he's easy mode,
because you're just basically rewarded for keeping him alive, essentially.
So, for instance, there's one gate where one side's locked, the other side is not,
and so obviously unlocking it on the left side with Grant will provide an easier path,
whereas the side on the right is a little more perilous.
But then there's other things where, like, if you don't have Grant to get this gate open,
you have to, you know, kind of try to find another way in,
and it involves going up a couple floors and then finding a hole,
falling through that hole to get through the area.
So it's a little more like, I'm glad, actually, that that exists.
But I also really like the use of the characters here, where, like, again,
I don't think Grant is making the game easier.
I think you're being rewarded for keeping these agents alive,
and they should all help you in those kinds of particular ways.
But it would suck if Grant was like, you know, you have to get to,
you're on stage five, and you have to make sure that Grant's alive at the very end of the stage,
or else you can't get to stage six.
Like, that sounds like bullshit.
Yeah, yeah. Well, yeah, it's good on them to have not done it that way.
Yeah, that would be a sin.
Because I feel like a lot of NES games do it that way, where it's like, yeah, you just, you failed.
If that's the case, if that were the case,
then it would have to be a game over if anybody died,
or at least, like, a continue situation.
Right. The game stages are not broken into the more traditional, like, action stages in games,
where you just take out enemies and get to the end of a level.
You are in, you know, different environments.
One of them is, like, just the streets with civilians,
and others are in, like, the Alps, and so on and so forth.
But all of these different environments require you to kind of, like,
it'd be nice to call them puzzles,
but they're really just, like, different ways of getting through the environments
that aren't just clear all the enemies in a screen and move along.
You're constantly tasked with basically just trying to figure out where you have to go next.
And I think that's especially true in the very first stage of the game.
The very first stage of the game offers a very interesting idea of what the whole game could be,
in the sense that you are just out on the streets.
There are regular civilians.
Unfortunately, the enemies dress exactly the same as the civilians,
but you're not allowed to kill civilians.
If you do, a helicopter will come and arrest you.
It's a pretty crazy scene.
You get down, like, on your knees, hands over your head,
the helicopter comes, and they take that character away.
Your other two agents are free.
Even though they witnessed it, they were right there.
It's totally fine.
So if you witness a crime, you should be arrested, Mike?
Yeah, absolutely.
They're government agents.
They basically coerced them into it.
Anyway, my next point was just going to be that, you know,
it's not inherently obvious, right?
Like, in that first stage, like, oh, I need to go here, then here, then here, right?
Like, a different game would do it that way, but this one doesn't.
It's also not obvious, like, what kind of game you're stepping into,
because when I started this first level and I walked into a bar
and the bartender gave me some info and not every NPC on the screen was trying to kill me.
I'm like, am I in, like, an immersive sim right now?
Like, is this going to be, like, sort of more open-ended in how I do this?
And then it very much was not that.
Like, it's basically just that first screen that feels more lifelike,
and the rest is, like, video game land.
But, yeah, the information that they give you, it's not complete.
You end up really having to figure out everything by yourself,
but it's also just a little misleading how the game starts.
Yeah. Well, and I was also, I mean, just from familiarity minorly with the franchise
and how it started, I was also surprised with how video game land it became,
where, like, and I was pleased with it.
I was glad that they didn't, like, take themselves so seriously that, like,
yeah, we can't have two giant magnets that pull your bullets in one direction.
Like, that's just, like, fun video gaming stuff,
and I got to imagine that kind of thing wasn't in the Mission Impossible show,
but as I'm saying that some of those 60s spy shows maybe did have giant magnets
that were, like, or, like, suits of armors that would, like,
would swing their swords at you or whatever.
Like, but having that stuff, or even just the idea of, like,
there doesn't need to be an explanation as to how you can be Grant
and then switch to Max and still be the same place,
and it's like, well, where was Grant before?
Where was Max before?
Were they in his pocket or whatever?
It's just like, eh, it's a video game.
Just, like, this is how the system works.
And I don't know why I, like, was surprised by that,
but I just feel like there have been other games where, like,
no, no, no, you've got to go back and get this character now.
It's, like, just, like, too much work to make it realistic
instead of just make it fun.
Yeah, and I think there's a lot of fun little set pieces
throughout the game, too.
Again, I was trying to, I didn't want to say puzzles
because it's not a puzzle game, right?
But, like, you have to, like, you're blocked off somewhere,
so you have to figure out, like, well, where's the off switch on this thing, right?
Like, how do I get past the next thing?
And you find, you literally find an on-off switch.
You just have to trigger that.
Or there's a certain, you know, you need to shut down the power,
so you've got to look for the power box.
Like, the game has creative ways of having you explore the levels
without getting too far away from the combat of it all.
So how is the combat of it all, right?
If the game is going to stake its name on that, is the combat fun?
It's simple.
There's kind of three or four different kinds of enemies
where you've got, like, a standard, like, melee guy
that will just rush you.
You've got gunners.
You've got these giant Molotov cocktail-throwing guys
that can really give you some damage.
Like, I think getting hit by one or just even stepping into the fire
that they leave behind will cut your health in half.
And throughout the game, like, there's robots that you've got to avoid
and, like, the aforementioned suits of armor.
So there's definitely a good variety of enemy classes.
It's just those special ones are a bit more rare.
And the riot shield guy.
And you'll have to deal with similar enemies throughout the game.
I'd say it is pretty simple.
Most enemies only take a hit or two.
It's more so just finding an angle to get that hit in
without getting hit yourself like we've been talking about.
I wouldn't say that there's anything massively wrong with it.
I wouldn't say that there's really much to really say about the combat
other than, like, oh, you've got to make sure, like, you know.
Because also, this top-down thing,
like, you're shooting from one of your shoulders, basically,
and you could miss what you think might hit.
So there's a little bit of a trick to it,
but no major sins, no major pluses.
Yeah, I'd say that more so than the way the combat is designed,
the way that the, I mean, I guess this is combat,
but the way that the, like, enemy design is around you
does, for better or for worse,
make it feel more tactical than a lot of other games
where it's like, yeah, like you said,
there's enemies that are shooting at you.
There's enemies that are, like, sneaking up from around corners,
and you've got to sort of, like, get the jump on them
when they're in the right spot,
where you can hit them and they can't hit you.
And there's enemies with riot shields
that are trying to push you off the edge,
and you've got to kind of get behind them.
And, you know, all these different little things.
I mean, there's even, like, if you get caught
by, like, someone you're talking to
that turns out to be an enemy,
or you get caught by, like, a camera or something,
these, like, giant, like, robot things or something
with claws come running in,
and they're, like, really aggressive.
It's just, there's a lot of different ways
you have to think about the different enemies,
which does make it feel,
I assume intentionally, like, you're this, like, tactician,
and you've got to decide who's going to take on this battle
and how am I going to take it on
in as much as, like, this kind of simple action game can do.
Why can you shoot the guys with riot shields?
Because they've got the riot shield.
Yeah, but I know, but they don't know how,
it's like three shots,
and you hit all three of them.
Like, aren't they supposed to be using the shield
to bounce off the bullets?
I think, okay, wait, you're asking
why can you shoot them?
Why can you?
Why can you do damage to those guys?
I think, like... Can you shoot them from the front?
Yeah, I did it.
I think there's one little part of their sprite
that has a hitbox,
and the rest of it is shielded,
because I have been cornered by one
and just, you know, spammed shoot
and could not break through.
I had to, like, lay a bomb.
I think there might be a little corner.
Maybe I have to get the head shot. Yeah, that is an exposed shoulder or something.
But yeah, I also don't want to gloss over
what you mentioned, Sean,
speaking of, like, this accuracy thing,
what you glossed over, or what you mentioned about the...
The fact that you are shooting
from, like, one side of your body
is a little weird,
because it's like you can never, like,
line up properly.
It's never just the thing
directly in front of you.
It's always, like, in front of you
and a little to your right.
Yeah, because the angle
that these guys can be standing in,
it'll just, like,
oh, your bullet just went right past them,
but there's no actual way
to line up the shot otherwise,
because it's also kind of grid-based.
It can be tricky.
That's the word I'll use.
Yeah, and, like, I know
they're trying to go for, like,
oh, he's using his right arm.
This is more realistic. Like, just have it shoot
out of the center of his body
so I can, like, easily see
where I'm going to shoot.
I found the game to be
pretty difficult for...
because of the enemies.
I think the combat
for, like, what your characters are given,
like, they control well,
it makes sense, the sub-weapons are good
and everything, but the enemy placement
requires a lot of
forced, closed combat
in specific levels,
and I don't think
it's in a tactical way.
It's almost in a way
that's, like, you kind of have to guarantee
taking a hit or two
just to even get these guys
to come out of their spots
to be able to progress
around them, and I found that
to be pretty difficult with the life meter
and just, like, me personally
getting through these levels.
I don't know if, like,
maybe I just wasn't thinking
about these combat situations
correctly, but there were a lot of times
where, like, you know,
you are on a bit
of a linear path
and to get through you must take out
these guys because they're shooting
at you or they're, you know,
using whatever they have
on you, and the only way
to get through is to, you know,
kind of have them
get out of those areas
and chase you down,
and so you have to kind of, like,
run over there and bring them back.
Yeah, you can kind of
kite some of them.
If you're playing
as Glass's guy
who has kind of, like,
a boomerang thing,
you can kind of
shoot around corners.
It's a little tedious,
but if your main concern
is I don't want to get hit,
it's probably the best way
to attack those guys.
If you go in
as Machine Gun Dude,
Max, I believe,
yeah, you're,
with especially how
plotting your walk speed is,
you're definitely going to get hit a lot,
but I was doing some
wanted bullet bending
with the eyeglasses guy.
And I also found out,
even just reading
through the walkthrough,
that some item locations
are randomized in stages,
so they're not always in the same place.
that's interesting. Yeah, maybe make for
some replay value.
What kind of, like, key items, I guess?
Yeah, like, you know,
just to go back to the first stage again,
like, where you got the pass
might not have been
where I got the pass.
Interesting. I also got the Maniac Mansion,
too, like, that kind of built in.
Well, at least there were,
there were numbers that changed.
I don't remember if there were locations,
but they were definitely like,
oh, you can't just remember
the number you typed
in last playthrough,
because you gotta, it's a totally new number now.
I mean, that would kind of trivialize the early part
of the game if they didn't do that.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah,
like, it doesn't enhance
the replayability, but it makes sure
the usage on that
doesn't trivialize it,
because if you just know
where everything is, and that's what was interesting
about the walkthrough, was like, it was like,
here's places it could be,
but I can't promise
it's gonna be that on your playthrough.
So I'm down for something
like that, especially in a spy game, right?
Like, you're gonna have to do some sleuthing.
Yeah, yeah, I mean,
if that's part of the design
of what the gameplay loop
is supposed to be, then, yeah,
make it so I can play it again
without just remembering everything.
I think it's a better call than what we saw
in Dick Tracy,
where you know
where everything is,
but you just have to do it
in this order, or it just doesn't work right.
Right. And there are some
other action sequences
in the game that, again,
lean into the, you know,
the tech and the Mission Impossible
side of things,
with the, there's a boat fight
and a ski fight,
and both of these,
you know, I guess could be considered
breaks from the other stages
and everything, but they're not, like,
they're not trivial
by any means.
They are cool, though,
that, you know,
now it's taking that, like,
action set piece
from, like, what would be, like,
a, you know, probably, like,
the finale of the TV show,
right, is, like, they made this huge
ski chase thing,
and now they're putting it
into the game.
Did either one of you
play through either of these sections?
Yeah. Just the boat section.
Yeah, just the boat section.
It's tough. There's just a lot going on.
Yeah, and there's even, like,
well, speaking only to the boat section,
there's even, like, the helicopter that you can't
even hit because they're accurate
about, like, the plane that you're on.
No pun intended because it's a helicopter,
not a plane. But, like,
the different planes
that you're on for being on the water
against something in the sky.
You can't shoot at it. You just gotta dodge,
and it's, like, dropping things on you.
Which I think if it was Ethan Hunt,
like, you know, if this was, like,
the movie version
of Mission Impossible
video game adaptation,
I think we'd be able to shoot at it.
Yeah, because it's like,
wait, is the gun mounted
to the front of the boat, or is it just in your hand?
Can't you just shoot up?
Handgun could take out a helicopter,
no problem. There's also
the addition of
side-scrolling levels,
auto-scrollers, I guess I would say,
not side-scrolling
because they're scrolling from top to bottom.
But, you know,
just another way to break up
the gameplay here,
but did you guys find
that maybe it was switching things up
in a way that, you know,
just switching it
to switch it, and that it wasn't
really, like, cohesive?
Well, I mean,
I didn't get much further
than the Venice level.
So, I,
the water fight
was a welcome change
to me. Because it's like,
not that I'm against
this gameplay, I liked this gameplay,
but it is a slow-moving thing.
It's nice to have a little pace change.
I don't know how
it would get, like, in, like,
the later levels, like the skiing one
or any of these other,
like, really change-up ones,
but I'm open to it.
Yeah, Mike, the only side-scrolling
that I saw
was when you manually
walked downstairs.
And if we want to talk
about weird walk cycles,
that's where I think we should really talk about it.
they're just being careful.
Maybe somebody put a mine
on one of those stairs.
That's a good point. And just to be clear,
I just mean, like,
overall with the game, too.
You know, we were talking about
how the first level
kind of sets up
an idea for, like,
what this game is,
and they kind of
abandon that. But then they do that
a few more times, too.
Whereas, like, you know,
the second stage
of the game,
and I don't even know what kind of level
that is. Like, what kind of
setting it's in?
Yeah, what setting? Is that, like,
a warehouse,
or is that...
It says it's a temple. I'm gonna go with
warehouse slash,
like, evil base.
Okay, yeah. I completely agree,
but don't they say,
like, oh, we gotta go to the Venice temple next?
Maybe. It's not like a temple.
Yeah, this does not
look Venetian to me.
Yeah. Let's see.
Yes, it's a... No, it's a temple
in East Berlin.
They just got out
of the canals of Venice
in the previous...
Uh, no. Never mind.
I'm out of order.
Okay, so you start
in Moscow. Okay, yes.
Now I see it.
Yeah, this definitely
looks...
This looks more churchy.
So maybe they're, like...
It's more of a...
An ancient mansion
in Venice.
It's the Syrinx Temple
of East Berlin.
You've left
the clammy canals...
The clammy canals...
What? The clammy canals
of Venice.
This is all from the manual.
And now you're in the Syrinx Temples
of East Berlin. And these are the specific canals
that lead directly
to East Berlin. Yes, everybody knows that.
Yes. Which lead directly
to the Persian Mountain Range
and then the famous
West Alps
and then Cyprus
and where does this end?
Yeah, this game ends
shooting by the dock
of the bay. What?
They couldn't commit to a final villain's
country origin?
Like, they just made up a place?
I think it's Chinatown.
Forget it. The boss fights
are also interesting.
One takes a hostage.
There's another one
where you can't step on the same platform
twice or it breaks.
I like that they're
changing that up, right?
And that it's not just like,
oh, here's just another
big, strong,
shoulder-swinging guy
who has all the same
stuff as you but he's stronger
and he has more health.
Yeah, it makes them seem like actual
villains from the show.
Like Monster of the Week,
episodic villains.
If that's indeed
how they are on the show.
Right. It makes them feel like
what they would feel like
if they were like that on the show.
We should have done
more research. I should have played
this game. Yeah, just on the show.
The show is the show
and this is not a podcast
where we check out
all the TV shows
but I will say
for whatever we've said
about the game which I think has been
a good mix of praise
and criticism, GamePro Magazine
gave the game
a perfect 25 out of 25
in its magazine
and I don't want
to spoil anything here
but a perfect score
I think that's reserved
for a particular kind of game.
Where do they think
about this 25 out of 25
nowadays? Would they stand by it?
I'd have to assume
that whoever reviewed it
for that publication
was really just itching
for the Mission Impossible
video game
and was just a huge fan
of the IP.
That's just a guess.
Or maybe they were paid off.
I do see
like I'm not
I guess I'm maybe
tipping tipping my hand
a little bit here. I don't think
this is a perfect game
but I can see
like how
the scope
of this game and the things
that you do
and the places that you go
and the
you know the more
fundamental mechanics
I can see
why someone would think
like wow this game has everything
and it's not
just and it's not
just a running gun
just more
DACA situation
like this is a game
where you have to be methodical
about what you're doing
it's it's kind of
Metal Gear-y
in that way I can see
that this scratch that there's
there will be people
where this
scratches a very specific
itch so I get it
yeah I mean I think
it's I think it's like
one of those situations
where you think of a game
like you think
of like Skyrim or something
when that came out
it's like wow
this is like the peak
of open world
games all this stuff
that we've never been able to do
before but now
in 2025 like
oh yeah that's interesting
that's a cool game
but like is that the peak
anymore is that like
are we all as hyped
on it or even
like GoldenEye
you know like that
was like the first person
anyone go back
and try and play that recently
like it's not really
fun but like
back then it was so
fun because like
it was so
unique yes
and are you
guys aware of
rival
video game franchise
Impossible
Mission didn't we
play that yeah
I thought that was an episode
already Impossible
Mission I just
think it's funny we have Mission Impossible
and then Impossible
Mission did we get
one on the NES I don't
know it sounds familiar
but I don't
think we played Impossible
Mission yeah that was a shot
in the dark I have no idea
okay yeah the original
game came out why do I
know what it is
well it's a series of
video games I don't
think it's any other kind of
media so did you play
Impossible Mission on perhaps
the PlayStation One
no okay
good so that
would have been impossible there was
no PlayStation I might
be on one of my other podcasts
that I Moonlight on
you played
Impossible Mission on the
Commodore 64 I know
you're a B64 head
that's true
yeah 64 head
C64 head
they call it
C I did not get confused
with the N64
they call it the C64
I was just confusing it with my
forehead right
so Impossible
Mission I don't
know I don't want to get too much into
this but basically
it's the same
thing right it's like a spy series
but they
couldn't use the Mission
Impossible name because
these games
came out in the 80s and
the TV series
already existed in the 60s so
they just said well what if we
just do it the
other way and I'm just wondering
is there anything
currently that that could work for
Mario Super
Brothers Throne Games!
Furious Fast!
Fast yeah I
like the addition of guys will
definitely protect you in
a court of law yeah
yeah yeah that's
true that would
definitely be
like a transmorfer
situation Morty and
Rick sure sure
don't know if
that would get you around
the loophole
and Mission
Impossible has some games of
its own other than
this one 1998
Mission
Impossible game just
called Mission Impossible
again but this time
obviously based on the Tom
Cruise movie came out for
the N64 the PS1
and the Game Boy Color
that game I did play
what'd you
think of that game I
like that
is kind of
what my first impression
was when
we first
booted up the way described it
like you are not
immediately
like attacking
people like you
start off kind
of undercover and almost in a
hitman style
are trying to
like navigate a place and
then only when
like your cover
is blown do you start
fighting so I
did like that game I didn't
really I wasn't
very good at it but I
did like there was a mission
that I can I can remember
very very very clearly
where you
are on some
like Russian military base
and you can steal like
ranking officers
face and then walk around as
if you are the
ranking officer
on the base it was very
cool it
really set up
what I expected
out of like yeah immersive
sim games and then there's
Mission Impossible
Operation Surma
in 2003 for the
GameCube PS2
Xbox and
Game Boy Advance and I always
think that's funny that was
a thing that happened a lot
right where like
you get the console games and
then you'd get obviously not just
the console game ported to handheld
it would be a completely different
game but there's
like there's so
many games like
that like that
just get like a
Game Boy Color entry where it
has literally the same exact name
and everything and plot but it
can't be the same
game the Game Boy
Color can't have what the PS1 had
and I feel like
somebody should
explore that we're
not going to on this podcast but
like somebody should explore all these
handheld titles of
popular like
console games
Mission Impossible
Operation Surma
starts to go and
maybe it was already
true of the original Mission Impossible
based on your
description Sean but Operation Surma
leans more into
the whole like Metal Gear Solid
Splinter Cell
Hitman style of
things you know
now that that
groundwork had been
you know fleshed
out fun yeah so
a lot of like you
know put the guy
to sleep pick him
up drag him into a
closet nobody else
will notice blah blah
blah you get it espionage and the
guy like the guy
looks a little bit like Tom Cruise but
it's not Tom Cruise
they weren't allowed to use legally
distinct com trues
yeah com trues is
that you said yeah
great band great
band is it a band
if it's just one guy it's just a guy
yeah great guy
great guy probably
and I'm just gonna
be controversial here for a minute
probably better guy
than Tom Cruise
I'd take com trues
any day that was a very hot
take yeah thank you
I appreciate it
I'll reserve until
I meet them both
we'll save our
next batch of hot
takes for the
essential games list
I like a lot of
this game mission
impossible and any
kind of like critiques
about anything other
than the combat are
more just like an
identity crisis of the
game itself and
sometimes that's like
sometimes that's just
what people want right
is like good I'm glad
that we didn't stick to the same thing
over and over again
so that I'm not
going to like single
that out I really just
think this is actually like a pretty tough
game and not in a way
that is like rewarding
to the player so for
that reason alone it's
not gonna go on the
essential games list for me but I would implore
people to you know not
just like just because
it's difficult right like
not check it out like I
do think especially even
just if you just play the first level and
say well I got my taste in mission
impossible I think that's like an
interesting enough film
like it definitely is
doing something similar
to what we saw with
metal gear without being
the same game at all
like they are not the
same kind of game so
it's taking the whole stealth thing in two
different ways one
because you're not really being stealthy at
all in mission
impossible where you
have to be in metal gear but you still feel
like a spy and you
have cool gadgets and
you have to like figure
out your way through
the streets of Moscow
one thing that was
like really funny was
like if you're just
hanging out in the
street eventually a
car will just like hit
you and you go flying
yeah you go you go
flying so far it's
actually the first thing that happened to
me in the game yeah
but it's like okay you
know what that's that's
like good that's like
in a weird way that is
like NES world building
in a way right like
it's silly it's fun but
it like it made you
think like wow I didn't think that there
would be just regular
passenger cars on this
street but here they are like they they did
a good job in all these
levels of making them
feel like something I
just don't feel like the
actual total product was
cohesive Sean yeah I
agree I kind of kind of
echoing what I said
earlier where I do see
who this game was made
for and that that person
would fucking love this
game and I do like the
game more so on paper
than in practice I
think it's indicative
that like there's a lot
of games that we play
where we just can't shut
up about how annoyingly
hard it is like it's
almost the entire
episode I can't think
of which one specifically
off the top of my head but they exist whereas
we didn't really touch
on how super hard this
game is which it is I
just think there was enough interesting stuff
going on under the hood
to talk about where it
kind of took a back seat
to that but that is why
I could really only get
through a couple levels of
this game and why I
probably will never finish this game but I do
think it's cool I do think
it's interesting I just
don't think it's essential.
Joe? Yeah I actually kind of
find it hard to figure
out put my finger on
exactly what it is about
this that that gave me
that same sort of I did
get kind of burnt on it
pretty quickly because
like yeah everything we're
talking about I'm like
generally describing it
as like positives and I
do think that they're
positives I think that
like maybe there's a
little like over ambition
to this game or something
that I get kind of like
maybe almost too lost
isn't really the word
but like it's taking me
too long to get somewhere
to make progress or I
think I'm I don't know
that the gameplay Luke
just wasn't fun enough
to really suck me in
for the amount of time I
have to spend figuring
out what to do next
but I do think that like
yeah I'm gonna echo what
both of you said I think overall this is like a
really cool game to check
out and I think they did
a lot right it just it
just wasn't up there with
the with the essential
games of the world so I'm
also going to not vote
of essential now take two
on this next week's game
has NES in the title isn't
that weird well I'm not
playing I think that's
exactly what you said last
week did I say that well
this way I'm actually not
going to be on next week's
episode so it's supposed to
be a funny setup that
people would have taken very seriously it's
supposed to be a surprise when we're not on an
episode Joe you can't just
announce that people thought
Sean was dead I will have
to be on the episode
nowadays yeah it's NES
play action football and I
I'm just gonna be honest I'm sure it's I'm sure it
was true of video game
magazines but I didn't
think Nintendo themselves
would refer to the NES
like on the box like that
like it's it's really weird I
don't want to get into it right now but it says
Nintendo and NES a lot on
the cover of this box like
more times than is
comfortable for me let's
talk about our podcast a
lot on that episode
that's a great idea but
you won't catch me dead on
that episode because you'll
be alive look at that in the
look at that in the
look at that in!